you know something that happened late
last week and then into this week the
original comments from bill belichick to
former patriots offensive coordinator
charlie weiss on sirius xm and then the
weei remarks where belichick was grilled
about this this perception slash reality
that he's making an excuse for what's
going on this year let's start with
and are we on the same page that he is
making an excuse some people are saying
oh he's just stating facts when he says
that this year was set up to be a rough
year from a cap standpoint because we
sold out to win super bowls
for now threshold issue do we agree
that that
constitutes making an excuse for this
year
mike i'm offended by the cons by by his
i'm literally offended that he would say
it so yes we're on the same page
okay now as to the accuracy of the
statement are we on the same page that
it is a load of bunk that there wasn't
some sort of selling out the future and
mortgaging future caps and pushing money
around and knowing that all along 2020
is going to be this reckoning where we
may be two and five through seven games
yes we are on the same page there and i
arrive at it in a different way than you
do but we both get to the same eventual
point
yeah i mean i thought ben volen's
article in the boston globe was very
instructive on the data points that show
there wasn't some ridiculous drunken
sailor spending by the patriots in past
years they were below the nfl spending
average the last three super bowl years
tom so there was never a sense you know
we've seen teams over the years and we
know when they are going to have to pay
the piper eventually we know they're
going to have a rough year we know the
chickens are going to come home to roost
and whatever other cliche we want to use
that was never the sense with the
patriots never the sense not that it was
a
a talent issue but not a cap issue well
the way i arrived at mike was to look at
it this way
the patriots pushed away from the table
on
homegrown talent that they should have
or could have had to pay chandler jones
dante hightower malcolm butler and jamie
collins all of them except for hightower
went out the door patriots made good
moves in doing that other teams paid a
high price for those guys
and wasn't proven that they were going
to be the missing pieces in those places
did the same thing with trey flowers so
they've sidestepped contract after big
contract who have they brought in in
terms of big three agents one stephon
gilmore they sidestepped for two decades
paying tom brady and anything resembling
close to market value
he hasn't had a 14 million dollar hit on
a cap mike until 2018 so for bill
belichick to act as if he's got cap
constraints and really i think it is
rock kicking over brady's 14 million
dollars in dead money
well we got that we also have antonio
brown which idiot reporters in new
england were telling you don't do it
before you did it same thing with
michael bennett what do you want him
he's dead money so you get 25 million
dollars worth of dead money between
those three guys in march
and now you're going to complain you
have the ball to complain about tom
brady's dead money after he gave you 20
years of good
of good fortune against the cap it's
crap it's four years the second round
pick spent on cyrus jones and jordan
richards and joe williams and kyle
duggar and
mohammed sunun
duke dawson and on mohamed sanu it's
really really really poor roster
management
and it gets back to brady covering
things up for him
okay now
let me ask you this before we pivot to
abe and tom brady together again in
tampa
i i had been told for years that the
patriot way consists of never making
excuses under any set of circumstances
typically in the context of injuries you
got an injury no excuse next man up and
the next man up is expected to perform
at the level of the guy he's replacing
we're not going to get long in the mouth
we're not going to say oh woe is us
we're not going to say it's not our year
and that applies to everything there's
never an excuse what stuns me the most
about bill belichick making excuses is
that the locker room is going to hear
this tom and they're going to be guys in
there that are thinking hey well that's
not our year right bill said so and
they're not gonna suck it up and they're
not gonna go out there and try to find a
way to scratch and claw and maybe steal
a seven seat and get hot in january he's
giving them license to say it's a crazy
upside down pandemic year and it's a cap
situation and we'll worry about 2021 for
football for now let's just get through
the season do you agree with that
mike think about this when you indicate
that you were all in and pushed your
cards into the middle of the table in
the other years
what does that say about this year what
does that tell your coaching staff about
this year if they're sitting there until
midnight every night getting ready for a
game in which they know they're out
there with a cap gun
we're not all in this year so does that
mean we can leave early does that mean
these players
[Laughter]
we were all in last year but now so the
players can go home to their families
instead of living in the hotel so they
don't bring cove at home i mean it is
again he's 68 years old the most
accomplished coach in perhaps american
professional sport history certainly the
nfl
but it just shows you how unbelievably
unfamiliar the territory is for him to
be two and five and having to explain
things um and i think football coaches
coaches in general but football coaches
are hardwired to find excuses make
excuses and whine
and some of the excuses that bill's
making do hold some water he's got eight
opt-outs to cover
and but you don't make excuses you don't
make excuses in new england that's
what's stunning to me tom
same
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports